-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden today,
traveled to Florida
and spoke about
Social Security and Medicare.
He didn't intend to, it's just
what everybody in Florida
was already talking about.
[ Light laughter ]
Democratic Congressman
James Clyburn praised
President Biden's
State of the Union performance
yesterday.
And said Biden displayed, quote,
"The kind of maturity
that the American people would
like to see in a president."
When you say maturity,
you mean this guy?
[ Light laughter ]
You're talking about this guy?
I think that's the maturity you
expect from your cool uncle.
"Hey, hop in kid.
We're gonna go to
Dave and Busters.
I got a bucket
full of quarters."
Senator majority leader
Chuck Schumer praised
President Biden yesterday
for baiting Republicans
into a bi-partisan agenda during
the State of the Union address
and said, quote, "He let
them walk into his trap."
That might be a little generous.
It's more like
when someone falls
running away from Michael Myers.
Was it a trap?
Or did Michael Myers
just get lucky?"
[ Light laughter ]
That's right, Schumer said Biden
let them walk into his trap
while Marjorie Taylor Greene
let a seal walk into hers.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene
yesterday defended her
heckling of President Biden
during the State of the Union
and said,
quote, "I don't clap for liars."
Well, whatever she claps for,
it's definitely on the
ones and threes.
[ Light laughter ]
You know what?
For the people who got it,
I think they're gonna
like it a great deal.
[ Light laughter ]
Do I think both you and I,
knew baze that wasn't
for everybody,
but for the people it was for --
Fred, did you like it?
-Oh yes.
-Yeah, there you go, see?
Some of these jokes
are for drummers.
[ Light laughter ]
North Korean leader
Kim Jong Un
was joined on stage yesterday
by his 9-year-old daughter
at a military parade unveiling
the country's new missiles.
So, I guess
bring-your-daughter-to-work day
has officially
jumped the shark.
[ Laughter ]
New York Congressman Nick Lalota
Referred to fellow
Republican representative
George Santos during
an interview yesterday as
a, quote, "sociopath,"
which ironically is the only
thing not on his resume.
[ Laughter ]
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy
met with King Charles yesterday
at Buckingham palace.
"How's the war going,"
asked Zelenskyy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Fire fighters in -- we should
say right now -- you know what,
this joke is very dependent
on a graphic.
We haven't seen it yet.
We're gonna find out in real
time if this joke pays off.
[ Light laughter ]
I think in the writing of the
joke,
he had a very clear idea
of what it was gonna look like,
and now we're gonna find out.
Fire fighters in Pennsylvania
were recently called to remove
a cake pan that got stuck
on a girl's head.
And right before picture day.
[ Awe's and laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
I guess you can win them all.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities in
Texas arrested a man this week
who they believe broke into the
Dallas zoo
and stole two monkeys.
Though when reached for comment,
the man was, you guessed it,
already busted out
by two monkeys.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We got...
[ Cheers and applause ]
a great show
for you tonight.